[Music]
do
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
okay
[Music]
um
[Music]
good morning to all of you
we are at the jacob javits center today
and this brings back a lot of memories
first
let's thank all the people who are
working here today the nurses the
doctors the technicians the national
guard let's give them a big round of
applause
[Applause]
i'm pleased to be joined by dr howard
zucker our health commissioner for the
state of new york
we have reverend gilbert pickett a
pleasure to be with him
mike kopi who works on the state
emergency management
and has been heading up to this
operation alan steele who runs
the javits center uh and this is a
phenomenal convention center but what
alan steele has had to do
over the past year no convention center
on the planet has ever done let's give
him a round of applause
[Applause]
and i want to thank the members of the
clergy who are here
for making a very powerful statement
today
and let me acknowledge them uh myself
out of respect
reverend cockfield bishop calvin rice
reverend johnny green
reverend anthony lowe reverend renee
washington
pastor sean gardner reverend carl warp
minister stanley smith bishop findlayer
pastor duckett reverend aker reverend
bolden
minister knight karina aker reverend
byrd
reverend newton rush reverend williams
reverend
carson reverend trollinger pastor
james osai kofi reverend merryweather
reverend
dr carl washington jr let's give them a
round of applause
i'm going to make some comments then
you'll hear from dr zucker
uh and then reverend pickett is going to
be doing the real work today because
he'll make some remarks
and then he'll be receiving a vaccine
coming to javits i was just chatting
with
dr zucker inside in many ways
it's emotional but being back here
javits
center in many ways represents the
beginning
and the end the beginning
of covid javits was turned in
to an emergency hospital
when we believed the hospitals were
going to be overwhelmed
2500 emergency beds
were set up at javits it had never been
done before
the entire floor was
a sea of basically
army cots and partitions
2500 as far as you could see
and it was being staffed by national
guard
and army personnel and we came down
to supervise the setup of the hospital
and i remember speaking to the national
guard
and these are young people who came from
all over the state
they're in this place that looked like
it was
a scene from a science fiction movie
it looked like it was after the
apocalypse
2500 hospital beds and the national
guard
were frightened you could see it in
their eyes
they're wearing masks they're wearing
gloves they're getting a briefing on how
the virus
transfers uh everybody's nervous
everybody's frightened but they showed
up
they showed up and that's what was so
powerful to me in this frightening scene
jeeps army trucks body bags
they showed up they showed up they had
the courage to show up
and that was the beginning and
we made it through it was a long year it
was a hard year it was a challenging
year was a frightening year
it was a painful year
death suffering anxiety loss
but we made it through we are now at the
end at the beginning of the end
why because we have a vaccine
that can stop the virus
we have a vaccine which is the weapon
that can win the war
we know that for a fact
well then why is it only the beginning
of the end because we still have to get
the vaccine
and president biden god bless him has
been doing a beautiful job on that
ramping up the amount of time that this
nation will actually have enough
production
for the country and then people have to
take
the vaccine we have to get it
we have to administer it but people have
to come in
to take it why is javits
symbolic of the end this center
is a mass vaccination center runs 24
hours a day
this weekend the javits center
did more vaccinations than any
place in the united states of america
that's what we're doing here at javits
we're also doing vaccines at 48 houses
of worship
across the state we're also announcing
today another
10 new vaccination sites
as the production from the federal
government is increasing
so as we're getting more we are ready
to distribute more but
it has to be done fairly it has to be
done fairly
and we learned this lesson the hard way
over the past year
covid discriminated
two times as many blacks
died as whites
two times as many blacks died
as whites think about that
black population had a higher infection
rate
black population had fewer covert tests
available black population had more como
morbidities more existing underlying
conditions
because there's a disparate health care
system in this nation
and there are health care deserts and
there are communities that are left
behind
and those people did not have the same
level of health care
and they fell prey to covid
at a higher rate that is the god's
honest truth
before all these pastors and clergy
members today
so when it comes to the vaccine
correct that injustice that covid
has brought to this nation and this
world
when we do this vaccine let's make sure
it's available to everyone
and let's make sure everyone is coming
forward to take it
now it is not
currently being
distributed or accepted fairly
new york city 53 percent of the
population
is white 57
of the people who have been vaccinated
are white
53 of the population 57
of those vaccinated
black population 27
of the people in new york city are black
only 18 percent of the people vaccinated
only 18 of the people vaccinated
hispanic 28 percent of the population
only 20 percent vaccinated
asian population 16 percent of the
population
23 of those vaccinated
the white population the asian
population
are getting vaccinated at a higher rate
than their population the black
population hispanic population
at a lower rate well
why is the question we are making
the vaccine available
on an equitable basis in community
centers in
public housing projects in housing
houses of worship
geographically all throughout the state
there is a hesitancy problem
in the black community now they call it
hesitancy
i don't like that word hesitancy because
it's a baloney word
hesitancy it's not hesitancy call it
what it is
it's a lack of trust it's a lack of
trust
the black community is saying i don't
trust the system
that says it is safe the black community
is saying too many times we've been told
to trust the system
and the trust was broken the black
community saying
do you remember the tuskegee experiment
and now you're asking me to take the
vaccine the black community is saying
well
the trump administration said it's safe
but i don't believe
the trump administration when they said
it was safe
by the way i am saying
i didn't accept the trump administration
when they said it was safe
but here are the facts
we didn't accept the federal approval we
then brought together the best
healthcare minds in the state of new
york
they all reviewed the vaccine they all
said
it was safe number one number two
i have no agenda besides representing
the people
that's what i do i don't represent
work for the politicians in albany i
work for the people of the state
i am telling you i have gone through the
research 5 million
people have taken this vaccine it is
safe i'm telling you
my mother i recommended the vaccine to
i'm telling you i am recommending my
daughters
when they're available to take the
vaccine
i'm telling you that the leading black
medical professionals in this country
say take the vaccine
the pastors were here today
who have no other possible agenda
no other possible reason
to mislead the black population
say take the vaccine
clergy pastors who are here today
they only work for one person they only
have one boss
their boss would not take kindly
to them misleading their congregation
when they say it is safe to take
the vaccine it is safe to take the
vaccine
we now have johnson and johnson one dose
much faster much easier and it's going
to ramp up
production we'll make it available
we're doing it in this site faster and
better than any place in the nation
but we need people to come forward and
we need the black population to come
forward
and we need the hispanic community to
come forward
they have to go first we can't put the
needle in your arm
if you don't bring your arm forward
and that's what we're asking you to do
today
this vaccine can save your life
this vaccine can save your mother's life
your grandmother's life your sister's
life your brother's life
it literally is a matter of life or
death
covet is over no it's not we lose people
every day to covet
every day i have to go through the
number of lives lost
well it's down from where it was yes
but you're still talking about hundreds
of families
affected every day every day
every day save lives
do what you can to save lives take the
vaccine
thank you for being with me today please
welcome dr howard zucker
[Applause]
thank you governor cuomo it is an honor
to be here at the java center this
morning
after a long year we now have three
vaccines
that will finally help us end this
crisis
it's never been so important that we all
do our part to get vaccinated
the sooner we can get vaccines into as
many people as possible
the better off we will all be herd
immunity will finally put covet on the
defense
and allow us to move forward there's
johnson johnson pfizer
or modernity each safe and affected
new york and the federal government have
each done rigorous reviews to guarantee
that's indeed is the case i'm especially
relieved
now have johnson johnson vaccine which
has been given out here at
center overnight it's only one shot it
doesn't require
the ultra cold storage that limits where
it can be distributed
these factors will allow us to get as
many doses of this effective vaccine
into arms as soon as possible the
government has been right when he said
that the vaccine is what will end of
this crisis
combined with our continued vigilance to
wear a mask and other behavioral
measures
the vaccine is driving down new york's
positivity rate
all three reduce the risks of covert
taking a tremendous burden
off of our hospital system so please
when it is your time get your vaccine
do it it's the only way we will end this
crisis
when we claim our lives and create a
better future for everyone
thank you very much
[Applause]
reverend pickett
to our governor and to all the
clergy we're here on today
it is a pleasure to be here as i am
personally preparing to take the vaccine
on today again i want to
acknowledge the clergy that the governor
has named and i especially want to
recognize my president
of the reverend dr carl washington of
empire
baptist missionary convention we stand
here today
united to encourage new yorkers
especially those who are part of the
black and brown community
to take the vaccine today some of my
colleagues
have already taken the vaccine and we
are a living testament to the fact
that it works and it is safe
the virus may be race blind
but it's not affecting anyone equally
it's hurting black and brown communities
disproportionately
so i want to thank the governor because
he saw the need to get
the vaccine to our communities and he
has not just
ringing the alarms of us taking the
vaccine for months
but he's been planning and acting to get
way ahead of this
for nearly a year i encourage
more houses of worship to take part in
the governor's
pop-up vaccinations the drives
in order to get members out to be
vaccinated in our
communities we are not just lucky but
blessed enough
to have three students retain johnson
and johnson
and uh dr stated take whatever
vaccination is available to god be the
glory
for the great things that he has done
and what he continues to do
now we must do our part
which means getting vaccinated to keep
ourselves our families
our communities healthy otherwise
we risk the ongoing cycle
of this virus rebounding and mutating
we need to stop this virus here and
now in these moments we must remember
the lessons
of the community in which john spoke of
in chapter number 15 of the gospel i am
the vine you are the branches
if you remain in me and i in you you
will bear
much fruit apart from me you can
not do anything the vaccine is safe
smart
and everyone should take it and that's
why
as a new yorker and as a pastor
i am taking this vaccine
reverend pickett makes a powerful case
he's a beautiful
orator but today the old expression he's
going to put his money where his mouth
is we're going to adapt it a little bit
he's going to put a
needle in his arm to show that he
uh truly believes uh
in this message back
for the reverend uh he deferred
uh and said he wanted someone with a
little bit more experience
i don't take it personally so
we have to praise the lord good decision
on the reference part
so reverend if you have a seat uh and
we'll we'll
watch you uh as you have your
vaccine administered thank you all very
much for being here today
[Laughter]
um
wow that was great
you